the vikings had a different dynamic in
the division around they had had a
hard-fought win unexpectedly in the wild
card round of the playoffs and that
wasn't enough to carry them over the top
they lost 27-10 to the san francisco
49ers now they have some decisions to
make some big decisions to make it looks
like mike zimmer is going to remain as
the head coach peter but he's entering
the final year of his contract here he
is at his end of season press conference
addressing his expectation that talks
aimed at extending his deal will begin
in the not too distant future
like i said a couple weeks ago was
talking about this
i love these players this organization
you know the owners have been
outstanding to me
so
uh i believe that there'll be
conversations here in in the near future
and uh whatever happens
i'm happy with it
i mean look the bottom line is you
either have to pay the guy or move on
from him i don't like the idea of
letting him coach his lame duck season
although it's happened frequently it is
a distraction as we saw or it can be a
distraction as we saw this year with
jason garrett in dallas it constantly
comes up what are you going to do what
are you going to do what are you going
to do i think the vikings know at this
point whether they want to keep mike
zimmer or not and the indications are
they'll find a way to try to extend his
deal but peter of the guys who have one
year left on their contracts gm rick
spielman head coach mike zimmer
quarterback kirk cousins running back
dalvin cook who would you make your top
priority in locking up beyond this
coming season
i'm tempted to say cousins but i think i
would rather say
mike zimmer
and i think the zimmer thing is going to
be difficult mike
just because mike zimmer's a competitive
guy
and i think every coach that has to
re-sign now who's had success mike
zimmer has this team as a contender
every year now obviously they haven't
gotten they haven't even sniffed a super
bowl you know or been close but
they have been a contender
every july when they come to training
camp so now you say my if i were mike
zimmer's agent my first
uh
my first shot out of the box to mark and
ziggy wilf would be
let's talk about matt rules contract
all right
and let's just start this thing at 8.7
million
uh a year
and and by the way we're not signing for
8.7 million a year you know let's talk
about a fair contract for a guy who's
had this team in contention
at the end of every season he's coached
virtually and so i think it's going to
be difficult i think the cousin's
contract is going to be exceedingly hard
just because
are you going to ask kirk cousins to
take a pay cut
uh probably not and now you have to ask
yourself
do you want to sign kirk cousins for the
sort of the near future
at 30 million dollars a year that's
that's one of the questions like i think
a lot of vikings fans would say even
though we know that uh he's not the best
quarterback in the league we need a
quarterback and we don't want to start
from ground zero so i think a lot of
people would say you just got to pay the
man
but when you pay the man
i
i i think i think that is a really
really tough signing mike
yeah i agree with you peter because the
guy has limitations and as we see more
and more mobile quarterbacks and what
you can do when you combine the ability
to throw the ball effectively with the
ability to move around to escape
pressure to extend the play kirk cousins
cannot extend the play the only way he's
effective is if the blocking is holding
back the pass rush which doesn't always
happen every game you can have multiple
occasions where somebody gets through
and you've got to deal with if you're
the quarterback they have the play
actions and the bootlegs that only work
if the running game is firing on all
cylinders it's a very basic offense they
have to replace kevin stefanski my guess
is it's going to be gary kubiak or his
son clint who takes over the offense and
they need a new defensive coordinator
it's apparently possibly maybe going to
be adam zimmer mike's son who's been the
linebackers coach for the last six years
so you know they have some adjustments
to make they have some big decisions
looming and i agree with you on cousins
you don't just pay him because he's due
to be paid or because the markets
continue to grow what does he really
give you he gives you a guy who can win
when you're playing against a lesser
team
but can he win when you're facing a team
with a great defense can he win can he
go point for point with a great
offense like the rams last year when
they weren't able to beat them in a
shootout in la on a thursday night i
just think there's a even though they
beat the saints and you got to give them
credit for that the fact that they lost
so convincingly and could get nothing
going offensively against the 49ers
makes me more inclined to believe that
what we saw last week was not some new
development and some new reality for
kirk cousins it was just you know closer
to an aberration and you'll get those
from time to time but to truly be a
contender you gotta have a quarterback
who can deliver far more often than once
a year in a big spot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports